This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So I think we were actually, were we on that side? And this is radio producer Sean Cole in New York City. This is a reenactment. We're just gonna lay this out the way it happened. I'm here with my friend Melissa at the Hudson River on the pierce where we were almost exactly a year ago
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。我想我们当时其实，我们在那边吗？这是纽约的广播制作人肖恩·科尔。这是一场情景重现。我们只是按事情发生的经过来还原。我和我的朋友梅丽莎在哈德逊河边的码头上，大约一年前，我们几乎就在这里
walking along, you know, casually, pretty drunk. We were. Drunk, talking about poetry. As you do when it's late and you're in a part of town, you've never been before. And it feels like anything could happen. It's spontaneously Melissa asked Sean to read her a poem. That one about things being dirty.
散步，你知道的，很随性，喝得有点高。我们确实喝高了。聊着诗歌。夜深了，身处一个你从未去过的新地方，那种感觉就是这样。感觉什么都有可能发生。梅丽莎随口让肖恩给她读首诗。就那首关于事物很脏的诗。
By the late great Franco era. Is it dirty? He'd read it to her before. Does it look dirty? He carried that ohera book around with him everywhere. That's what you think of in the city. Does it just seem dirty? That's what you think of in the city.
出自已故伟大的弗兰科·奥哈拉之手。这很脏吗？他以前给她读过。这看起来很脏吗？他把那本奥哈拉的书随身带到各个地方。这就是你在城市里的想法。这只是显得很脏吗？这就是你在城市里的想法。
You don't refuse to breathe, do you? Someone comes to you. Sean's a huge oherara fan, which will become important in about two minutes. So anyway, they kept walking and walking. Until finally, they wind up in a little plaza. Now we're at like a plaza. A plaza framed by two decorative fences
你不会拒绝呼吸吧，对吧？有人朝你走来。肖恩是奥哈拉的超级粉丝，这在大约两分钟后会变得很重要。不管怎样，他们一直在走，一直走。直到最后，他们来到一个小广场。现在我们就像在一个广场。一个由两扇装饰性栅栏环绕的广场
with an opening between them, two fences. Right. They hung out there for maybe 20 minutes, not noticing anything. And then we kept walking to keep on going and I went, cheers words. Actually, I remember me being there's words.
中间有一个开口，两扇栅栏。没错。他们在那儿待了大约20分钟，什么也没注意到。然后我们继续走，接着往前走，我说，天哪，有字。其实，我记得当时我说的是有字。
Oh, I can be, it's funny. It's funny. Words, and one of the fences. I said like, wait. Not carved or inscribed into it. It says something. But wrought into the very metal of the fence. It says, but wrought into the very metal of the fence.
哦，我可以，这太有趣了。这太有趣了。有字，在其中一扇栅栏上。我说，等等。不是雕刻或刻在上面的。它上面写着什么。而是直接融入了栅栏的金属之中。它上面写着，而是直接融入了栅栏的金属之中。
It says, Contributions here, city of the sea. They go down the length of the fence. City of war, reading and stores, word by word. City of tall facades of marble and iron, proud,
上面写着，“贡献献于此，大海之城。”它们沿着栅栏延伸。“战争之城，阅览与商店”，逐字逐句。“大理石与钢铁的高耸立面之城，骄傲的”，
and passionate city, metal sum, mad, extra, extra-agent city. Walt Whitman. It was a passage from Whitman, another poet, Sean Loves, and a big influence on Frank O'Hara. Walt Whitman? They've run back to the beginning of the sentence.
“充满激情的城市，金属之太阳，疯狂、奢华的城市。”沃尔特·惠特曼。这是惠特曼的一段话，惠特曼是肖恩喜欢的另一位诗人，也是弗兰科·奥哈拉的重要影响来源。沃尔特·惠特曼？他们跑回了句子的开头。
It starts over here. In the fence, the fence, city of the world, for all races are here, all the lands of the Earth make contributions here, all the lands of the Earth make contributions here. City of the sea, city of warfs and stores, city of tall façades, of marble and iron proud and passionate city. Metal sun, mad, extravagant city. And there's more holy crap that It's Frank O'Hara!
它从这里开始。在栅栏里，栅栏，“世界之城，因为所有种族都在这里，地球上的所有土地都在这里做贡献，地球上的所有土地都在这里做贡献。大海之城，码头与商店之城，大理石与铁的高耸立面之城，骄傲而热情的城市。金属之阳，疯狂而奢侈的城市。”还有更多，天哪，这是弗兰科·奥哈拉！
It's Frank O'Hara! That's right, the second fence is forged into a line by Frank O'Hara. And it goes like this, one need never leave the confines of New York to get all the greenery one wishes. I can't even enjoy a blade of grass unless I know there's a subway handy or a record store, or some other sign
这是弗兰科·奥哈拉！没错，第二扇栅栏上锻造着弗兰科·奥哈拉的一行诗。它是这样的：“人们永远不必离开纽约的范围就能得到自己想要的所有绿意。我甚至无法欣赏一根草叶，除非我知道附近有地铁或唱片店，或者其他任何迹象”
that people do not totally regret life. That people do not totally regret life. It's from O'Hare's poem Meditations in an Emergency. If you're a madman fan, you've probably heard of it. Sean bent down and scooped his brains up off the concrete. You have to understand. So I write poems and poetry is just never treated with this kind of reverence and architectural permanence. Do you know what I mean? It's like you don't... No, no, I totally know. I mean, you see the poetry and motion placards
“表明人们并没有完全对生活感到遗憾。”“表明人们并没有完全对生活感到遗憾。”这出自奥哈拉的诗《紧急状态中的沉思》。如果你是《广告狂人》的粉丝，你可能听说过。肖恩弯下腰，把他的脑浆从水泥地上捡起来。你得明白。我写诗，而诗歌从来没有受到过这种崇敬和建筑学般的永恒对待。你知道我的意思吗？就像你不会……不，不，我完全懂。我的意思是，你看过“诗歌在行动”的海报
on the subway, and that's nice. This is like the balusters of the fence. I look that word up. The spokes of the fence come down and bend around each letter, and they sort of hug each letter, and each letter is painted gold. Not joking. And then like, oh wait, it's these two poets with whom I have like an entire life
在地铁上，那挺好的。这就像栅栏的栏杆。我查过那个词。栅栏的辐条伸下来，环绕着每个字母，它们有点拥抱每个字母，每个字母都涂成了金色。没开玩笑。然后就像，哦等等，这是这两位诗人，我对他们有着一生的
of obsession. I mean, like I wrote, I promise I won't go on too long about this. But like I wrote I promise I won't go on too long about this. But I wrote 50 pages of academic Goldigook about Whitman for part of my college thesis. And O'Hara is like my poetry boyfriend. Like I'm just like, one thing I thought he was my poet. You know what I mean? Like you have those artists that you carry around with you and you're like, you've heard of him, you know, good thing.
痴迷。我的意思是，就像我写的，我保证我不会在这上面啰嗦太久。但是就像我写的，我保证我不会在这上面啰嗦太久。但是为了我的大学毕业论文的一部分，我写了50页关于惠特曼的学术废话。而奥哈拉就像是我的诗歌男友。就像我是那种，有一段时间我认为他是我的诗人。你知道我的意思吗？就像你有那些随身携带的艺术家，然后你心里想，你听说过他，你知道的，这很好。
And so to see him, a, you know, rot in metal, you know, is one thing. And b, rot in metal next to the poet, he, O'Hara saw, as like his, I think he called him like my great predecessor, his big influence. It was the last thing I expected to encounter that night. And I'm glad we went back because it occurred to us sitting there this time. You know, I bet it's dated somewhere.
所以看到他，a，你知道的，融入金属中，你知道的，是一回事；而b，融入金属中，就在那位诗人的旁边——奥哈拉将他视为，我想他称他为我的伟大先驱，他的巨大影响。这是我那天晚上最意料不到的遭遇。我很庆幸我们回去了，因为这一次坐在那里时我们突然意识到。你知道的，我敢打赌这上面某处标有日期。
Really? Yeah, I bet there's a date on it. Yeah, in fact, it says the Plaza Caesar Pele that's P-E-L-L-I, Scott Burton, Sia Armajani, and M. Paul Friedberg. 1989. We definitely did not see that last time. We were like, who did these things and when? Who will we ever know? Always read the plaque. I looked them up.
真的吗？对，我敢打赌上面有日期。对，事实上，上面写着“广场，西萨·佩里（那是 P-E-L-L-I），斯科特·伯顿，西亚·阿尔马贾尼，以及 M·保罗·弗里德伯格。1989年。”我们上次绝对没看到那个。我们当时想，这些是谁做的，什么时候做的？我们怎么可能会知道？永远都要阅读铭牌。我查了他们。
Caesar Pelley is one of the most influential architects in the world. Scott Burton's an artist. He died of AIDS in 1989. Cia Armajani is alive. He's another artist, living in Minnesota. And Impal Friedberg? Impal Friedberg's office is down the street from my apartment in Manhattan. Hi.
西萨·佩里是世界上最具影响力的建筑师之一。斯科特·伯顿是一位艺术家。他于1989年死于艾滋病。西亚·阿尔马贾尼还活着。他是另一位艺术家，住在明尼苏达州。至于M·保罗·弗里德伯格？M·保罗·弗里德伯格的办公室就在我曼哈顿公寓的街区向下。嗨。
I was looking for Impal Friedberg. Turns out he's really one of the four runners of urban landscape design. We sat down for 15 or 20 minutes, which quickly became almost an hour. In part because of this whole Homeric feud behind the building of this fence. You ready? Yes, Homericized way. Okay. So Caesar Pelley was the main architect for the entire plaza, and he tapped our guy
我在找M·保罗·弗里德伯格。原来他真的是城市景观设计的先驱之一。我们坐了15或20分钟，很快就变成了一个小时左右。部分原因是因为建造这个栅栏背后有一场类似荷马史诗般的恩怨。准备好了吗？是的，用荷马史诗般的方式。好的。所以西萨·佩里是整个广场的主建筑师，他启用了我们的人
Friedberg as his consultant. And I was very pleased. And normally, after the design was built, you would find places for the art to be located. And then you would go out and select the artists that you wanted. Now, that is the traditional, historically, the traditional way to go. I hear a butt coming. But this time, someone else was calling the shots, a planning official, basically. Uh-huh.
弗里德伯格作为他的顾问。我非常高兴。通常情况下，在设计完成后，你会为艺术品的安置寻找空间。然后你会出去挑选你想要的艺术家。现在，那是传统的，从历史上看，传统的方式。我听到一个“但是”要来了。但这一次，另一个人在发号施令，基本上是一个规划官员。嗯哼。
Kind of. I can't remember his name. I'm sorry. Anyway, this official comes along and says, we want you guys to work with an artist. And the architects are like, sure, of course. But then the official goes, no, you don't quite understand. We want you to use an artist as a co-equal member of the design team. Whoa.
算是吧。我记不清他的名字了。我很抱歉。不管怎样，这个官员走过来，说，我们想让你们和一个艺术家合作。建筑师们说，当然，没问题。但接着这位官员说，不，你们不太明白。我们希望你们把艺术家当作设计团队中平等的成员。哇。
Yes. That is, the artists are going to have just as much control as the architects. That's, so that was unheard of kind of. It was really unheard of kind of. It was really unheard of exactly. I'm architects in general, or we're unhappy. We're taking away an assignment, a piece of turf that architects have always had. Richard Khan is the guy's name.
是的。也就是说，艺术家将拥有和建筑师同等的控制权。那是，所以这可以说是前所未闻的。这真的是前所未闻的。这确实是前所未闻，没错。建筑师总体上很不高兴。我们被剥夺了一项任务，一个建筑师一直拥有的地盘。理查德·卡恩是那个人的名字。
Richard Khan. I'm Richard Khan. Former head of the Battery Park City Authority, which controlled this project. We argued him and then he said, you don't quite understand, that's the way it's going to be, whether you work on it or not. Oh, wow. So he was threatening your jobs, basically.
理查德·卡恩。我是理查德·卡恩。巴特利公园城管理局前负责人，该机构控制了这个项目。我们与他争论，然后他说，你们不太明白，事情就是这样，不管你们参不参与。哦，哇。所以他基本上是在威胁你们的工作。
So the artists were chosen as usual through a competition. Now, we were not part of the judging either. This is a fate of complete for you guys. Absolutely. We were complete for you guys. Absolutely. We were handed these two guys. Sia Armijani and Scott Burton, the two other names on the plaque, so they're both artists. And Scott happened to be acquainted with Franco-Hara. I brought them along to the room.
所以艺术家像往常一样通过比赛选出。现在，我们也没有参与评判。这对你们来说是一个既成事实。绝对是的。我们完全是为你们。绝对的。我们被塞了这两个家伙。西亚·阿尔马贾尼和斯科特·伯顿，铭牌上的另外两个名字，所以他们俩都是艺术家。而斯科特碰巧认识弗兰科·奥哈拉。我把他们带进了房间。
We met them for the first time. And I said, I would like you to come up with a wonderful plan for the public space. So it's sorry, it's a very chilly hospital environment with the running i need to do suspiciously i mean you know i mean they just knew what the others were saying about and uh... and how badly um... and just you know each didn't want the other to be involved
我们第一次见到他们。我说，我希望你们为这个公共空间想出一个绝妙的计划。所以很抱歉，这是一个非常寒冷的医院环境，伴随着我需要做的事情，可疑地，我的意思是，你知道，我的意思是他们只是知道对方在说什么，以及呃……以及多么糟糕，嗯……还有，你知道，彼此都不想让对方参与
and it was and again it was on principle so i just left them alone close door left just called me when you had something to show. So we met once. And they went on for a number of weeks. Met twice, met three times, and began to develop a certain trust in each other. They fell in love with each other. And we established rules. And the rules, I think, were essential. If any of us, there were four. If any of us, any one of us, did not want the design that was proposed. Of the other three, it had to be discarded.
而且，这又是出于原则问题，所以我只是把他们留在关着门的房间里，有东西要展示时叫我。所以我们见了一次面。他们持续了好几个星期。见了两次，见了三次，并开始在彼此之间建立某种信任。他们爱上了彼此。我们确立了规则。这些规则，我认为至关重要。如果我们中的任何人——总共有四个人——如果我们中的任何一个人，哪怕只有一个人，不同意所提出的设计。其他三个人的设计就必须被抛弃。
It got time to do the fence and see his idea, not Scott's even, okay? It was primarily see his idea, because it also was part of his tradition. See is from Iran, where poetry is actually not mocked openly. One need never leave the confines of New York to get all the greenery one wishes. He selected a quote, not the rest of it. I can't even enjoy a blade of grass unless I know there's a subway handy. And read and took Sia's idea or a record store
轮到做栅栏的时候，这是西亚的想法，甚至不是斯科特的，好吗？这主要是西亚的想法，因为这也是他传统的一部分。西亚来自伊朗，在那里诗歌其实不会遭到公开嘲讽。“人们永远不必离开纽约的范围就能得到自己想要的所有绿意。”他挑选了一句引文，而不是剩下的部分。“我甚至无法欣赏一根草叶，除非我知道附近有地铁”，然后阅读并采用了西亚的想法，“或者唱片店”
and made it work physically. Or some other sign in the fence. That's my job in this. That people do not totally regret life. So I called Sia Armijani, and he didn't want to be interviewed for the radio. He did however want to go out for coffee sometime and talk about poetry. He said many people, many poets, of what was known as the New York School of Poetry, John Ashbury and them.
并在物理上使其成型。“或者栅栏里的其他标志。”这就是我在这当中的工作。“表明人们并没有完全对生活感到遗憾。”所以我给西亚·阿尔马贾尼打了电话，他不想接受电台采访。不过，他确实想什么时候一起出去喝杯咖啡，聊聊诗歌。他说很多人，许多诗人
Called him after the fence was unveiled to thank him for such a wonderful tribute to their friend and colleague, Franco-Hara. O'Hara's sister, Maureen, called. There were tears, he said, to thank him. I mean, I just wanted to be in touch with him. This is Maureen O'Hara. Can I just say how electrocuting it is to talk with someone who shares the same genetic material as your personal messiah? Your brother is my favorite.
属于被称为纽约诗派的诗人，约翰·阿什贝利他们。在栅栏揭幕后给他打电话，感谢他为他们的朋友和同事弗兰科·奥哈拉做出了如此美妙的致敬。奥哈拉的妹妹莫琳打来电话。他说，电话里有泪水，为了表达感谢。我的意思是，我只是想和他取得联系。我是莫琳·奥哈拉。我能不能说，和与你个人精神导师共享相同基因的人交谈，是多么触电般的感觉？你哥哥是我的最爱。
Oh, the Shawner, you wonderful. It's true. She says she loved the idea from when they first mailed her the design on paper. The drawings were sent to me in 1985. And when she finally saw it in the flesh? I was, I was just absolutely astonished and delighted. And it was, it was very emotional. Plus just aesthetically she said, the thing is brilliant. And the letters are formed, and they are set into the railing, and they shine, and they sparkle.
哦，肖恩，你太棒了。这是真的。她说，从他们第一次把纸质设计图寄给她时起，她就爱上了这个构想。设计图是在1985年寄给我的。当她终于亲眼看到实物时？我，我简直是惊呆了，欣喜若狂。而且，这非常令人情绪激动。此外，仅从美学上讲，她说，这个东西太棒了。字母成型了，它们被镶嵌在栏杆里，它们闪闪发光。
I mean, it really must have been quite a surprise. It still is today, to me. I feel the same way. And Frank would have loved it so much, just as he loved collaborating with his friends. You know, I mean, because really, in the spirit of it, it's so collaborative. So collaborative. And it's especially interesting in that poets do not get this kind of attention. I know. I was, that's why I was so shocked. I'm like, not only is it poetry, but it's Walt Women in Franco-Harrif. I know. I was that's why I was so shocked. I'm like not only is it
我的意思是，这一定是个相当大的惊喜。对我来说今天依然如此。我有同感。弗兰科一定会非常喜欢它，就像他喜欢与朋友合作一样。你知道，我的意思是，因为真的，从精神内核上讲，它是如此具有合作性。如此具有合作性。尤其有趣的是，诗人们通常不会得到这种关注。我知道。我当时，这就是为什么我那么震惊。我想，这不仅是诗歌，而且是沃尔特·惠特曼和弗兰科·奥哈拉。我知道。我当时，这就是为什么我那么震惊。我想，这不仅是
poetry, but it's Walt Women and Franco here. I feel like that's a deep cut and like I know. You know, normally poetry so either maligned or ignored. And it was so wonderful for Walt Whitman. I mean, yes, let's not forget. Oh, it's just it would just be such a thrill. But to me, I think poetry, I think there should be poetry should be in our garden, in our parks. This again is... Impulse Friedberg, right. And this actually taps into a major design principle of his. I think information should be layered in our environment. Information should be led cultural information. It should be layered in the environment. Not didactically. It should be an integral part when I say layered that if you are interested you extract it. A wall, it's a structural entity. How do you express that? It has force,
诗歌，而且是沃尔特·惠特曼和弗兰科·奥哈拉。我觉得这是一个很冷门的梗，然后我知道。你知道，通常诗歌要么被诋毁，要么被忽视。这对于沃尔特·惠特曼来说太棒了。我的意思是，是的，我们不要忘记。哦，这简直会是一种巨大的激动。但对我来说，我认为诗歌，我认为应该有诗歌，诗歌应该在我们的花园里，在我们的公园里。这位再次是……保罗·弗里德伯格，没错。这实际上契合了他的一项核心设计原则。我认为信息应该在我们的环境中分层。信息应该被引导，文化信息。它应该在环境中分层。而不是填鸭式的。它应该是一个整体部分，当我说是分层时，如果你感兴趣，你可以提取它。一墙，它是一个结构实体。你如何表达它？它有力量，
it has power, okay? That's a very important part of it. So the way you design the wall, but then again, the wall is also a billboard, okay? So how do you then express, what kind of information do you express on a billboard? It can be decorative, it can be color, right? It can be anything, right?
它有能量，好吗？这是非常重要的一部分。所以你设计墙的方式，但话又说回来，墙也是一块广告牌，好吗？那么你如何表达，你在广告牌上表达什么样的信息？它可以是装饰性的，可以是颜色，对吧？它可以是任何东西，对吧？
Like that. The idea that you're looking at a fence and yet you walk away with the thought as well. The fence is a barrier. So you almost have like a contradiction here. It breaks the barrier, okay? Poetry breaks the barrier. The idea that it doesn't stop you.
就像那样。那种你看着一栅栏，却带着某种思考离开的想法。栅栏是一道屏障。所以你在这里几乎有了一种矛盾。它打破了屏障，好吗？诗歌打破了屏障。它不会阻挡你的想法。
It begins something, you know? So, I'm making that up as I go. As I go. Yeah. So where do you end up with all this? It's funny. Melissa and I sort of had the same thought about it when we went back again for the second visit this time. About Whitman and O'Hara sort of looking down on the fence from some place. I hope they know. I don't even know if I believe in the afterlife, but it would be cool if they knew. You really would be, I think think about that all the time.
它开启了某些东西，你知道的？所以，我是边想边编的。边想边编。是的。所以这一切最终会导向何方？这很有趣。我和梅丽莎第二次再去拜访时，对此产生了一种相似的想法。关于惠特曼和奥哈拉在某个地方俯视着这道栅栏。我希望他们知道。我甚至不知道我是否相信来世，但如果他们知道那就太酷了。真的会的，我想我一直都在想这个。
Really? Yeah, it would especially be cool for, for O'Hara. And it really makes me want to go back in time and say to Franco Hara, it's going to be okay. gohara. It's gonna be okay because one day a line from a poem that you wrote or in fact that you may have yet to write will be ensconced in bronze in a fence in New York City next to a line by Walt Whitman. So don't worry. If somebody came and said that to me, I think I'd, I think I'd, I'd, you know, feel a lot better than I usually do. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sean Cole, Melissa O'Donnell and me Roman Mars.
真的吗？是的，特别是对奥哈拉来说会很酷。这真的让我想回到过去，对弗兰科·奥哈拉说，一切都会好起来的。奥哈拉。一切都会好起来的，因为总有一天，你写的一行诗——或者事实上你可能还没写的一行诗——将被安放在纽约市一处栅栏的青铜中，紧挨着沃尔特·惠特曼的一行诗。所以不用担心。如果有人走过来对我说这样的话，我想我，我想我，我，你知道的，会感觉比平时好得多。99% Invisible 本周由肖恩·科尔、梅丽莎·奥唐纳和我罗曼·马斯制作。
Two gay poets too, I might add. Really? It's a project of KALW, 91.7, local public radio in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. It's the punctuation against me. Yeah, it kills you. Perentices in a fence! Come on! You can find this show and like the show on Facebook.
顺便说一句，这也是两个同性恋诗人。真的吗？这是旧金山当地公共广播电台 KALW 91.7 以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。这是针对我的标点符号。是的，这会要了你的命。栅栏里的括号！拜托！你可以在 Facebook 上找到并喜欢这个节目。
All of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links, and listen to all the episodes of 99% invisible. You must go to 99pi.org Radio to the end. For PRX. Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们所有人都在 Twitter、Instagram 和 Spotify 上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括精美的图片和链接，并收听 99% Invisible 的所有单集。你必须访问 99pi.org。节目到此结束。由 PRX 提供。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。